bonsoir jean marie théodat merci d'être
avec nous le report le référendum pardon
reporter c'est un mauvais signal selon
vous le référendum principe pour moi
plutôt un bon signal signe que le la
voix du peuple a été sinon clairement
entendu mais en tout cas interprété par
le gouvernement dans le sens de la
possibilité de la tenue de cette
consultation qui est comme vous l'avez
dit illégal impopulaire et surtout
inopportune parce que nous sommes dans
une période de recrudescence de la
pandémie de covile 19 en haïti et ce
n'est vraiment pas le moment d'organiser
des meetings d'aller voter dans des
espaces qui ne sont pas véritablement
prévu pour recevoir des foules surtout
qu'aucune nouvelle date a été n'a été
proposé ça dit quoi
vu le temps extrêmement court qu'il
reste au président pour organiser le
référendum puis les élections
législatives et enfin les élections
présidentielles je pense que en fait il
s'agit d'une sorte de de reconnaissance
de de la défaite en fait de toute la
stratégie qui consistait à passer en
force dans cette année électorale
et finalement on peut se compose
maintenant s'inquiéter de la façon dont
il va sortir du bois parce que le
gouvernement est quand même tenu
d'organiser des élections législatives
et présidentielle ça fait les affaires
de l'opposition qui aura davantage
fait-on pour contester cette procédure
je pense que ça ne laisse pas davantage
de temps l'opposition mais ça donne
surtout du fondement aux revendications
de loups passe tellement de l'opposition
ils sont de la population de façon
générale parce que l'opposition n'est
pas non plus à ce point unis au point
qu'on puisse dire qu'elle parle d'une
seule voix
mais néanmoins on peut dire que
l'atmosphère sociale va dans le sens
d'un rejet assez massif de la politique
du gouvernement et c'est ce que
l'annulation de ce scrutin vient
finalement confirmé pourquoi
l'opposition ce stade est légal et
légitime sets constitue cette
constitution est fait de façon d'abord
que tel et ne prévoit pas de
consultation de type référendaire entre
l'exécutif et la population ce qui est
une clause de sécurité par rapport à
tout dérapage populiste ou dictatoriale
du régime
donc c'est prendre le contre-pied des
garde-fous qui avait été prévu par la
constitution de 1987 pour empêcher le
retour au pouvoir des duvalier donc
c'est anticonstitutionnel
c'est illégal parce que cela se passe
dans une atmosphère où les deux chambres
haute et basse qui sont censés
représenter le pouvoir législatif et
faire contre eux contre pour
contrebalancer le pouvoir exécutif ne
sont pas en mesure de le faire parce que
les deux tiers de cette chambre ne sont
pas actuellement active et c'est une
mesure enfin qui est il légitime parce
que ce régime corrompu qui est largement
discréditée au sein de la population n'a
pas la légitimité pour organiser cette
consultation dans la mesure où eux ceux
qui sont considérés comme le problème du
pays ne peuvent pas en plus être la
solution
le président moïse tellement de
manoeuvre at-il sa marge de manoeuvre
est extrêmement limitée d'un point de
vue légal
et d'un point de vue de point de vue
patriotique au sens que à partir de
l'année de l'année prochaine c'est à
dire en scellier 2022
il est censé passer la main à un
successeur dans l'intervalle il faudra
qu'il ait réalisé les élections
législatives les élections
présidentielles et nous n'avons ni les
moyens matériels ni la paix civile
nécessaire et ni surtout la légitimité
politique de ce gouvernement pour
organiser de telles élections
donc tout laisse penser que nous allons
vérité
le monde vers une impasse vers une
situation où ne pourront pas sortir de
la situation de l'impasse
constitutionnelle créé par le
gouvernement et donc qu'il va continuer
à gouverner par décrets donc de facto
nous allons vers une dictature
que va-t-on justement c'est elle pendant
la prochaine question que peut-on
espérer comme dénouement politique pour
vous ces dictatures ou ou rien est ce
qu'il n'ya pas à scénario plus optimiste
malheureusement le scénario le plus
réaliste c'est une nouvelle mise sous
tutelle de la souveraineté nationale
dans le cadre d'une mission de l'onu
mais cela s'est déjà vu à trois reprises
depuis la chute de la dictature des
duvalier donc n'avons pas grand espoir
attendre de parler de paris expédiant et
il ne semble pas non plus que le
soulèvement populaire la contestation
dans les rues soient suffisantes pour là
pour faire tomber ce régime
donc en fait nous allons probablement
continuer à vivre d'escarmouches une
escarmouche comme cela se fait depuis
une dizaine d'années entre le
gouvernement et l'opposition
donc en fait le pays est en train de
faire du surplace merci jean marie
théodat géographe ce que c'est elle qui
mène de conférences à l'université
panthéon-sorbonne mercier d'avoir été
avec nous